all right my popular Instagram pictures
from this week of course i'm on
instagram at david pakman let's go first
to the first of the most popular
pictures from my instagram account this
week i tweeted over the weekend myself
sitting cross-legged no less with my
Kosmos by carl sagan book this is a book
I recently finished I never read the
book previously I know this is a book
that lots of people read a long time ago
it is from the early 80s fantastic book
I am probably going to recommend this on
an upcoming recommendation segment have
you ever read the Kosmos path I have not
may have a new TV series right with Neil
deGrasse Tyson I'm gonna have to check
that out yeah oh the new TV series is
great the original book is extraordinary
obviously like with everything that I
post to Instagram immediately I was
criticized because I waited too long to
read the book yes the book was written
before I was born and I only just now
read it but I read the book isn't that a
good thing shouldn't we be focusing on
that no I think we should focus on the
fact that you read sitting on the floor
crisscross applesauce : yeah I welded
let's move on to picture number two
please before this becomes an even
bigger scandal okay the other very
popular picture from my Instagram
account over the last week David Pakman
is a drawing of me by Instagram user I
am Lord this is very cool this is based
on a travel picture I posted a few weeks
ago during our show vacation and it was
me reading at a cafe in Brussels Belgium
and that has been turned Patt into this
drawing of me and I think it's pretty
cool I like this yeah very calm
expression there which I think drives
with the style of art and I would love
to see a YouTube livestream thumbnail of
yours done in this style as a drawing
right yeah that is interesting so anyway
if any of this sounds interesting you
can follow me on instagram at david
pakman and thanks to IM lor for putting
that picture that drawing together very
very cool